clint called me i answered my phone he
was like he was like oh my gosh you got
the cover
i literally ran down the hallway
screaming
and skipping i was so happy and all my
friends were like
what are you doing and i was like i got
the cover of entrepreneur magazine and
they were like what's that
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense today i talked to
alina morse who is a 14 year old
business mogul she has a multi-million
dollar company called
zollipops she had an idea when she was
seven years old seven to
create a lollipop that was actually good
for your teeth instead of bad for your
teeth
and you know sure enough then by the age
of nine she was already on tv and
the product was on the shelves which is
amazing it's now in 25 000 stores
she is a fascinating young girl she's
very mature
um i see a lot of myself and her she
is uh we talked about how her life has
changed we talk about the dynamics at
school now
we talked about the family dynamic
because essentially she
employs her parents so we talked about a
lot of really heavy topics for a 14 year
old
but i wouldn't have gone there if i
didn't think she could handle it
please enjoy this show i wanted to start
off by
asking you about um your idea binder
that you had when you were three years
old
i mean i can't even remember being three
years old but you had an idea binder is
this right
yes i i had an idea binder where i kept
all of my
my great inventions from ages
like three to seven
um i still have it but what's in it
um you know lots of
lots of product ideas that you know had
probably already been invented
but you know i was like oh i'm being so
original like i wanted to put like
peanut butter and jelly in the same jar
and then i got like really upset when i
found out it was already a thing
yeah i was like i can't believe like
they'd steal my idea like this
it's just it's preposterous um what else
i had an idea when i was probably
four or five it was you know pretty soon
after my dad read me the book rich dad
poor dad
um and my dad had worked as a business
consultant
you know wait how old are you now 14.
you're 14. yes
your dad read you the book yes when i
was four or five
and um interesting choice i was getting
the line the witch in the wardrobe but
anyway and then i'd sit there and my mom
would go are you sleeping i'm like no
mom i'm just resting my eyes
and i hate reading
well um so you know after he kind of
read me that book
i was definitely intrigued
in the world of you know
entrepreneurship and helping people
through business
which was a an important lesson
in that book and you know i grew up with
my dad traveling a lot he was a business
consultant
and you know like the the thing i wanted
most of the world i was like oh well i
i'm going to create a robot daddy and
it's going to be a robot that goes to
work for my dad so he can stay home and
he doesn't have to travel
and he doesn't have to do anything if he
can stay home when he can play with me
and you kind of manifest that on some
level
yeah i i held him captive and
until he helped me create a company yeah
um
and now he works with you or you i don't
know how do you say it how do you say
that
technically or do you work for me it
doesn't work for me okay
but it's an awkward position because my
parents worked for me too
so we can get into that in a minute i
mean technically
you know he's been working for me since
i was born but
interesting but now it's just on now
it's just on the tax returns
on all the official documents so
lollipops zolly pops that wasn't in your
did that end up in your idea binder or
was this
or was this where you threw the idea
binder in the closet because you didn't
need it anymore because you came up with
the best possible idea
well you know at first it just
seemed like you know oh this is just one
of my
one of my other inventions and i was
like oh it's going to go in the idea
binder i'm probably not going to do
anything about it
i'm going to obsess about it for a
couple weeks so my parents are going to
say something else and i'd be like oh my
gosh i have another idea
um but really i wrote down like a plan
um in my idea binder like for lollipops
i just you know wrote down just like
lollipops with a stick colored them in
and i was like i have a business plan
tell me the story tell me the story of
how you got that idea yeah
so um when i came up with the idea uh i
was actually on a trip to the bank with
my dad
um and the bank teller had offered me a
lollipop and my dad
told me you know you shouldn't have
candy because sugar is terrible for your
teeth
so i asked him i was like why can't you
make a healthy lollipop that's good for
my teeth
so that i could have candy and you
couldn't say no
and you know it kind of started out i
was like oh well this is
like this is perfect because this is
something that me and all my friends can
have
and our parents just can't say anything
about it we have all the lollipops then
yeah i'm good yeah we can just eat candy
whenever we want um
and you know i really wasn't expecting
it to turn into
you know a a multi-million dollar
company or
something that you know is sold in
target
kroger like all the places that my mom
took me grocery shopping like my entire
life
and you know i
just like from that plan and the idea
binder
to a real thing so that was at seven
right
yeah and then two years later it's on
the shelves
right yes two years later is for sale
yes how
i want to talk about that process
because businesses are hard to start
inventions are even harder so um
[Music]
your dad told you you need to do your
research is that right yes
i i told him i was like when are we
going to make these lollipops and he was
like
you know alina if you want to get
something done you have to do the
research you have to write out a plan
you got to do the work so what did you
think of that
i was i mean it sounded fair i was like
okay
you know like dad i'm a dreamer i'm not
a i'm not a researcher
that's what i would be thinking um so
what did you i mean like what was your
sourcing like how did you
how did you research at seven i mean
geez encyclopedia britannica was what i
had at seven but
the world's a bit of a different place
now well he he gave me a couple
different websites he said okay
well like check amazon check a couple of
the like larger retail
um websites to see if there's actually
anything like this
um so your dreams didn't get crushed
kind of like the peanut butter and jelly
in the same jar
yeah yeah my that was a tough time i
want to make sure that you understand
that my invention when i was a kid
because there was invent america
was um i created the easy reader which
was
um a book shelf like so your book would
sit up so you could look at it
and then it had like little buttons in
the back where you could raise and lower
the back of it
and a spot for your pencils in the front
pretty sure that existed
and then my other really great idea was
that i wanted to
that i made tic tacs that also brushed
your teeth i just basically covered tic
tacs and
in um toothpaste so
anyway those didn't work but tell me
tell me about how you got yours to work
well um so after
i i like checked amazon i checked
probably like walmart.com
other other you know retail uh
websites and i found that there wasn't
actually anything
uh like what i was thinking like i i
found like sugar-free candy but it was
like
where there's russell stover like your
grandma's purse candy
and there was nothing that was like
cleaning your teeth
nothing that was sugar-free and fun
like that was definitely something i
noticed like all the sugar-free was kind
of dull it was kind of boring
and i was like well kids aren't going to
want to
eat sugar-free or things that are good
for you
if they're boring and they don't get
boring
well you know like when you think
sugar-free at least when i think of
sugar-free i think of those little like
caramel candies that my grandma has
and i mean she'd be like oh do you do
you want a
caramel candy no grandma no i i want
real candy not not that um
not the candy that's been in your purse
for at least a year
so you wanted to create something new
exactly you didn't want some old new
version of an old
product you wanted something new yeah i
wanted and
it was like there was nothing like it so
how did you go
so so so you do some research you
realize that it's not available anywhere
nobody makes this from what you can tell
then what then um i started
researching um not only
like flavors and colors but i also
looked at like amazon statistics so i
was like well
you know i look at the best-selling
products
and i look at you know what flavors
are in like the best-selling bag what um
what are it was i want to say the top
six
um it was like strawberry grape
orange watermelon um watermelon wasn't
in there
what i know we just i know i love
watermelon
we just made watermelon pops um
but we uh it was strawberry orange grape
raspberry and um
what was the last one lime
no it's on here
you made them cherry cherry of course
that's what it was of course
and then we like one of our like big
like family
it's not even like a tradition but like
our family always eats pineapple
like just fresh pineapple yeah yeah
pineapple just wonderful love pineapple
and it's like we were like oh well let's
let's get a little crazy
let's add a pineapple flavor well you're
making it for you at the end of the day
right
you're the one who wants the you know
healthy lollipops so why wouldn't you
make your own flavor
exactly um and that's actually gotten
like really great feedback it's like on
amazon for the single flavors it goes
strawberry and then
pineapple so that's interesting then
what
i mean we still have to make a product
here you're still you're still cooking
on a computer right
and that's like doable i can we can do
i'm not
i would do that research but now you
have to like make the thing yes
so you know we were doing the research i
i found all of this like
information about oh like lollipops are
the
the most preferred uh hard candy out of
kids
and like all of these like random facts
um
along with what is now our mission
statement uh which is
um so tooth decay is actually the single
greatest
epidemic facing kids in america today
according to u.s surgeon general
and it's a preventable disease so
you know not hunger
well i mean at least what i think about
is
when i think like the number one
epidemic i think it will in america at
least i think oh
asthma food allergy food intolerance
which are all
on the rise and you see them in your
everyday life lack of confidence
things like that yeah very detrimental
yeah
but i definitely wouldn't have thought
tooth decay yeah and when i found out
that it not only was number one but it
was still growing at a rapid rate
i was like okay now now we have a
mission behind this
okay i want to stop this
and then i just watched youtube video
after youtube video on how to
make hard candy so they were just video
um
videos from like manufacturing
facilities making
mass hard candy okay that i looked up
it's pretty hard to translate to your
kitchen i would imagine oh yeah
so then what like tell me about your
first experience
making hard candy in your kitchen well
it wasn't it wasn't a walk in the park
um i
first had to beg my parents to let me
buy the ingredients
um which were well i had like taken an
ingredient list
of like a normal lollipop and that i
would i like replace the sugar with like
stevia yeah
and like i yes like natural like flavors
and colors and things like that
um which was like our like very
first like ingredient list right was
there like beet juice and things like
that in these to give you
color yeah like yeah um turmeric
yep annetto um beet juice
for the blue ones we just made blue uh
blue lollipops um like a blue raspberry
flavor
and it was like impossible to find a
blue and it turns out it's like algae so
like that's really interesting yeah
yeah yeah there's like blue magic or
something there's some there's some
weird ingredient that
is out there that's put in like health
food smoothies and
you know bowls and whatnot it looks so
cool on instagram because it's blue and
it turns out it's something super
healthy
yeah yeah i i found that really
interesting too because in the beginning
i was like dad like why can't we have
blue
yeah cause like that's not natural yeah
i was like no kidding later i found out
i have a blue dye allergy so
oh fun well that's okay right because
you can use something natural in it
exactly
yeah that's fine but like the blue one
and like blue lake like
oh yeah those things that you see on the
ingredients yes and you're like what the
hell is that
yeah it's blue like yellow number five
what are you
it's some kind of chemical compound that
i don't want to know what's in it
um but you know like in the beginning
like we were like oh like
this is this is all gonna be so healthy
and everything and so i i went to the
store i bought the ingredients
i'm at home i'm in the kitchen i'm like
boiling sugar
um i had like my parents like order like
a thermometer on amazon
yeah and i was like oh i'm so sciency
like i had a
oh i can't remember oh i had like an
apron i had like a chef's apron and i
was like oh my gosh i'm like a mad
scientist
like doing this experiment um but i'm
like
i'm putting like hot sugar on like
parchment paper and like putting it in
the oven
or like oh really is that what you do is
it supposed to know
or is it just cool it's just supposed to
cool
okay yeah i i was like oh yeah it needs
to be even hotter
than the boiling sugar it just yeah that
makes sense
like it's not firming up i must need to
turn the volume up
but um it like exploded
in the oven and then i tried the
microwave of course you know plan b
why would i clean up the oven when i
could just use the microwave where was
your mom and dad at this point in time
to recommend
maybe not the microwave banging their
heads against walls they were watching
please
stop alina but i wasn't going to stop
they knew i wasn't going to stop
i'm very tenacious we were kind of
playing around cause i'm getting a
feeling like
this wasn't super serious you were i
mean you were just playing
i was taking it very seriously you were
you were seven
so let's all put it in perspective here
i mean i get it
but you were also like if someone if a
seven-year-old my sister was five
three and five-year-old if her
five-year-old wanted to make something
kitchen like whatever
do whatever you want with it it's just
for fun yeah
i mean i was definitely very serious
about
making it yeah um but kind of at this
point i was
i was definitely thinking like i don't
think i can make it myself
okay then so that no that's makes sense
i mean you're
you're seven so then how did you get
help to make it
into the right into a formula that would
work
so um i went and i talked to my dentist
and my dental hygienist
after arguing with my parents about not
cleaning up the kitchen who told you to
talk to your dentist
um it was my idea because i figured
well i mean my thinking behind it was if
i want to make something that cleans
your teeth
why don't i talk to the people that i go
to to clean my teeth i don't know
you're a fed good water girl
[Music]
well i live at least 30 minutes from
flint zone you know
you know we had maybe they've improved
their formula yeah
no it was a minor problem it's all fixed
now oh yeah sure
it's all great you guys are still here
no cancer no tumor is good yeah
yeah we have a great water filter
fantastic
uh so you know i talked to my judges on
my dental hygienist and they're like oh
well we've used xylitol and erythritol
we've seen it in mints
um they use it in their like foamy teeth
stuff that they put on your teeth
to clean up gross or i don't know lots
of dentistry things that i don't really
understand
um but like they're like oh well we've
seen xylitol nerve with retail used in
mints that are
you know allegedly cleaning your teeth
um
and like different gums use xylitol
uh not only as like a a teeth cleaning
product but also as a sweetener
um because it's plant-based it's all
natural
and so i was like oh well maybe i'll use
those so
i had uh then i then
we started looking for um like a food
scientist to work with
so after i had kind of like written down
what ingredients i wanted to use like i
was like oh like i want xylitol
erythritol
isomal like which is like the
the base for like a lollipop oh yeah of
course
it's like instead of using sugar that
like crystallizes
that's basically what what you did your
research so yeah you knew so i just kind
of like
had like written down the the
ingredients but i had no idea how much
to use or anything so
you know working with this food
scientist we we kind of went over
okay so for the strawberry one we're
gonna use this color this flavor
like this extract um and this is how
much we're using of each of them
per like batch of i don't know a hundred
um and then we did with that with all
the flavors uh we only had
five flavors at the time um because
later that year we had added cherry
as like valentine's day like cherry
sweetheart
for your oh i can't even remember what
it is it was like cherry for your
sweetheart yeah cherry for your
sweetheart that's what it was
um so that was that was later but
you know we started off with those five
flavors and then we
we traveled around to different um
manufacturing facilities
which are really called plants but right
i mean so at this point in time has
everyone helped you for free
well we we paid the food scientist okay
i mean
my dentist wasn't like well i just
helped you so you know
right you went in as a seven-year-old
for advice and he
just gave you some advice right yeah and
then the food scientists though
well we hired them to right so is this
person part of the team now or was this
just
it was just uh it was just kind of like
a a consulting
kind of just like one time like and we'd
worked with like different food
scientists so like how much did that
food scientists cost
you're seven oh i don't know it wasn't
that much
did you pay for it yes we did you paid
for it
well we put together a budget for this
okay so
i your parents are helping you at this
point right yes yes
my parents were very supportive of yeah
my business ventures
okay um because it kind of they kind of
realized that i was like doing the
research and i was putting the work in
and they were like okay she's serious
like all right it's no different than if
your kid is interested in playing sports
and you have to go get
a mitt and you know a bat and a ball
or you know cleats or whatever it is
that supports your sport
or activity say you want to go to
tumbling class and you
you know it's a membership and you have
to pay for you know each session i mean
they all cost money so it makes sense
you're really interested in this and
they supported you
exactly in this in this area yeah yeah
um so like in the beginning like
we when we were kind of this was like
about on the stage like when we found
out that
we wanted to find a manufacturing
facility this is when we kind of like
put
the budget together i literally took
like my
money like from like birthdays christmas
grandma i was like hi grandma
i'd like to start a business donations
um but you know i i you always
were you were you entrepreneurial sort
of growing up like i will do these
things for money like
did you get paid to clean your you know
you know make your bed and take the
garbage out or anything like that did
you go
deliver newspapers did you i mean when i
was a kid i remember when
uh i wrote a little book of poems and it
was
you know copied on a copier and i
stapled it together in the top left
corner and it was called poems poems
poems
trust me i did not spell poems right i
did not spell it poems i
spelled it p-o-m-e p-o-m-e-s poems
yeah and not good spelling still um but
anyway i went and sold them for a dollar
so that was my entrepreneurial sort of
interest when i was at that age so did
you
have that in you did you i mean like i'm
just trying to figure out how at seven
eight nine years old you had really any
money
well you know your grandparents are like
oh
we're gonna put this into our college
fund but then it kind of just ends like
it kind of end up like just like sitting
as cash in my piggy bank
i'd get like ten dollars for my birthday
that really isn't gonna go very far for
the scientist
so i mean we came up with
um i don't know well i came up with a
certain amount of money
my dad and my mom like matched it
with like a little bit more why are you
being so why are you being so vague
right now
well because i'm not very good at math
and so i was like trying to split
seventy five hundred dollars in two but
then i was like i can't
and then i'm gonna start counting on my
fingers and it's gonna be a whole thing
well see now you'd see that i can
totally relate my math skills are super
poor so
i'd be like seven oh yeah eight thousand
divided by two is four
then never mind skip it it's 75 divided
by two
[Laughter]
so that was the plan moving 7500 divided
by two
which is something that someone
listening would know it's i feel like
it's like a
it's a decimal yeah probably um so
so that was the that was the amount that
it took to move forward
to manufacture this product yes um
so you know with that 7 500 we took it
um to different manufacturing facilities
and or or plants as they call them in
the in the candy industry
and really when we were going to like
tour these plants i
like one of the times like at the very
first uh tour we were like going through
the entire thing and at the very end i
was like you know
dad like this was a really cool
experience like it was so great to see
like how they actually make candy and
like not seeing it in a video
but where's the plant he looked at me he
goes
this is the plant and i'm like
no like a plant with leaves and you're
like no this is a facility
yeah he's like no no this building is
the plan they're trying to use some
psychology on you to call it a plant
like it's supposed to be real
positive it's a manufacturing facility
it's a bunch of
iron and equipment yeah yes
but i was like okay so you get the first
product i get to see the plant so
like i want how many versions how many
versions came out before someone
manufactured the product
um we did about 18 plant trials
okay so oh wow with the with these
manufacturers
yes oh wow oh 18 different ones
they were like or like we would do like
a few
so yeah each would do a few okay there
were maybe was it a clear winner did you
have like a clear
winner not at first did it come down to
price
no it kind of came down to
who had the facility that we could do
not free so that we could make the claim
that it's not free
right um right who had it so that
i mean we weren't just making like a
normal lollipop we were making a
sugar-free
lollipop so it was it had to be used on
different equipment than
sugary lollipops so we they had to have
separate equipment
and working with xylitol and erythritol
that needs special equipment as well
so we were we had to be selective
of plants that even could manufacture it
um but you know in the end it all came
down to okay this one's not free
this one is closer to us or further
from us or it just kind of it happened
in a way that we were just kind of like
okay this one
is just are the manufacturers the one
that then distribute your product for
you too
no so we um will do the manufacturing
there they'll ship it to they'll either
do the bagging
at the manufacturing facility or in some
cases
we have another warehouse that bags
so there's they just send the bulk um
candy there
and then they'll bag it from there
that's more for like the bins
or the individual flavors because we
only sell those on amazon
um and in a couple select uh
retailers um like world market at the
grove um
and just as uh that's just smaller um
portions of bags that we need so
um and then we do
a very minimal amount of packing
in-house
um that's only for displays
so okay um but from
we don't really ship from the warehouse
we usually or we don't usually ship from
the manufacturing facility we either
ship
from one of three warehouses
the one warehouse that packs the one
warehouse that handles
um a couple retailers so like some of
the bigger retailers
that have you know so many stores that
we can't keep all the pallets
in our warehouse where our offices um
we'll ship them out of there uh just
straight out of the
separate warehouse and then our
warehouse we do more of our
international orders from there
um because we need like several pallets
for international orders
so they're not continuing you said
office and it makes me
uh want to know who's on your team like
how many
employees are part of solid pops or is
that the name of the company
so the the name of the company is zolly
candy okay
um it originally was lollipops but we
changed it to kind of sure you know
umbrella over all of the products as we
expand to more
and currently who works in like the
zali office we have six people
and then we have four other people i
have two employees
and then we we directly employ 10 people
so six of them work in our office four
of them work
around the world um so my publicist
clint he work
he lives in la so like we directly
employ him but he just doesn't live in
michigan
um and then our head of sales lives in
pennsylvania
but we directly employ him as well as
along with
a couple other people and then we all
i mean in total we probably impact about
300 jobs
um from the manufacturing to the packing
and do you have investors we do we do
have
um they're more like angel family and
friends investors
um which are the only ones that we've
you just have money that grows on trees
you got all kinds of stuff going on you
come with 7 500
you have angel investors it's magical
i mean yeah you know i mean and it's
working which is amazing but
so did you have to give away a part of
your company
uh yes yes but small amount
10 to 15 yeah that's always the thing
it's always the so is the tough thing
when you have your own business and
you're like
i came up with it and i i dreamt this
into existence and somebody wants to
have a
chunk of it and but you know that you
can't do it all yourself exactly
um so you know that's the challenge is
like how do you get by
with as much doing as much as you can
and giving away as little of your
company as you
you possibly can and i mean who advises
you on that because
i i mean look look maybe you're doing it
all yourself
if so you're not really 14 i don't
believe you um
but uh but who like how who's giving you
business advice
well who's teaching how they stop all
these words who's teaching you the word
umbrella and like
i mean i'm just trying to think when i
was 14 i just don't
feel like these were this was the
language i was speaking so
umbrella who is it well i mean you're
talking about like an umbrella company
for like you know
zolly candy for all of the you know
these are just not
concepts of normal 14 year olds are
really like wrapping their head around
well and so who's advising you or or is
it all you
and do you read books like how did you
get to this point
well um i'm you know when you sit in
enough business
meetings you just kind of learn you
learn a lot of new words
it's lots of fun i'm still not great at
spelling but i do
i have some i can relate i still have
some
some pretty nifty vocabulary words
um that i have just like learned from
just like sitting in meetings with with
people that are just like you know
whipping out just like 12 letter words
i'm just like
okay like i got the longest word i knew
when i was 14.
um but really my dad is doing a lot of
you know advising um he
works in the company like on a
day-to-day basis and he likes
his full-time job now right yes he
manages it when i'm at school
um because you know
yeah when you're a freshman yep how do
you
who decides uh how your time gets
divvied up
is this your decision or is this your
parents decision
it's a little bit of both um
you know they they're very um
they're very supportive of the company
but they also know that it's important
for me to have
like my real like childhood experiences
and
tell me about your real child tell me
tell me about real childhood
minus being a business mogul
um well
you know i feel like well i feel like
it's definitely that's a hard question
because this was
a big part of my childhood okay but it
doesn't mean you don't go to school and
you don't like
you know um have a boyfriend or go to
parties
or um you know talk about talk about
getting a car
you can't speak this language and not
have been a party i'd think that you're
lying it's because your dad's sitting
here isn't it i don't
i i don't i don't have any of those
three things that you just mentioned
i don't know yet because you're 14 but
do you think about that like do you go
to
um do you play in any kind of sports
do you are you artistic do you play an
instrument
um you know what do you do for like what
do you what do you and your friends talk
about
can you relate at school i mean like is
this are you are you at a point right
now where you're like
i don't fit in like i don't i don't i'm
not entertained or interested
in the monotony of school and i
i would rather do this other thing
that's so much more fulfilling and
stimulating
and biology's just really not doing it
for you
well um you know i definitely tell me
about your fun things that you do with
school and then we'll talk about how you
relate in school because i think that's
important
i'm curious about that so outside of
school i'm a competitive dancer
so i'm on a dance team cool um i've been
honest since what kind of dance
all kinds so jazz tap hip hop
contemporary modern lyrical
holy crap what am i missing usually
someone identifies with one
right but we do it all wow that's
awesome
um so i've been dancing since i was like
two and a half and i started my
competition team when i was seven
uh it was seven seven
being a seven-year-old it was lots of
fun for me i was doing competition days
i was building a company you know they
say your life is they say there's like
seven year cycles with your life so
you're at 14 now which is interesting
i feel like a lot of interesting things
happened last year that was like my life
yeah about every seven years yeah seven
year cycling you know
six year cycle same thing okay so you do
dance yep um
so that's a couple days a week uh i also
just joined my school's palm team
okay i got on varsity so that's as a
freshman
yeah wow very cool that's very exciting
um so you know football games those are
going to be fun
football games in michigan are always
very cold but yeah
still fun yeah you won't be able to just
wear that skirt all the time
you'll have to have the pants on
underneath we have to wear this girl
not no pants what i mean i was a
cheerleader in illinois where i grew up
and
oh it's cold and it's cold you get to
wear the pants if it's that cold
man that's not fair that's okay all
right
that's cruel you might rethink that
december 27th
i i think i i have a feeling they might
um but you know like outside of school
i hang out with my friends like my like
best friend
in the entire world we're like attached
at the hip um
because we never went to the same school
until now so now we're gonna be
freshmen together on the varsity palm
team
okay doing dance together and going to
school together and i've been feeling
we're gonna get really sick of each
other i know i'm just kidding
but you know besties never never get
sick of each other
well you know when you just grow apart
that's what happens either you grow
apart or you grow together
it's true it's just what happens though
yeah you know but you don't get sick of
each other you just grow apart
yeah that's true but when you're
spending one night at her house then one
night at my house and one night at her
house
oh no we're going back to your house and
we're going to spend the night again
i have a family no no you don't you're
cancelling yourself so do you have a
boyfriend
boys don't like me why because i'm never
at school
is that why i'd like to think so
maybe not threatened by me i mean i
dealt with this when i was young i mean
i raced from the point
from 10 years old i was gone all the
time on the weekends um
i had my own thing i
i i said that they were intimidated by
me
um i've always been a very strong person
so that could be the case plus you could
drive and i could drive
and you know they know if they if they
broke your heart you have a car
so i know you had a little redneck crazy
on them um
no i i think that that was part of it
though you know i mean i think that
you know there's a male female dynamic
is really interesting
and you know in this archaic way of
thinking men are supposed to be like the
provider
and strong and you know it's just a
shifting dynamic in this
in the world where men and women are on
the same playing field and
men can support a strong woman and um
you know you might find yourself not not
you might not be able to find a really
good person
for a long time because you're in a
really interesting spot
where you're not only doing really great
things as i mean
you're 14 doing you're doing amazing
things at 14
and it's probably going to be hard for
people to relate do you i mean what do
your
you know minus the dynamic of friends
like guys um like what do girls say
about what you're doing
i mean you know do they get it do they
even get it because people didn't even
ask me sometimes about racing i'm like i
wish you'd asked more when i was in
school
because i kicked ass i won all the time
and you didn't ask me now i'm an indy
car and you asked me and i'm like i
finished fourth i finished eight
i finished 10th i finished fifth you
know i'm like should i ask me back when
i was winning every single weekend but
they didn't really
ask about it a lot because it wasn't
really part like i had i explained that
i had two lives i had my home life
where i went to the parties when i was
home and i
you know was a cheerleader and i hung
out with my friends
and you know then away from there i had
a whole different set of friends that
were at the racetrack and that was a
whole different life for me but they
didn't really
they didn't go together exactly yeah so
is it do you experience
something i definitely experience like
the exact same thing
um you know especially like not
being there i kind of like miss
you know like oh tommy and
sally got together and then they broke
up and then they got back together
and i have no idea what's going on and
quite frankly i don't really care
whether tommy and sally got back
together no is this because you're not
in touch with it or because you feel
like
you have better perspective on perhaps
what's important well
i feel like i've always been told you
know just
rise above it is it going to matter
in you know four years once you've
graduated high school
whether tommy and sally are still
together or if they're broken up
no so just for a country song
and you know i just kind of feel like
i definitely i definitely still have
lots of friends and i still am like in
the loop
but it's just kind of like
you know do i really does it really
matter
all that much if i miss a party because
i i i'm a teenager of course i love
going to parties and i love
you know hanging out with my friends and
you know i do want to do that and so i
make time for it
and my parents help me make time for
that and because i think it's important
as well
um so i guess i definitely think that
you know that that's important to have
that balance
um but really
people like what like when you said like
people don't really ask you about
people didn't really ask you about you
know oh like how is racing like
people don't care that i that i do yeah
like i could say like oh my gosh like i
was the youngest person on the cover of
entrepreneur magazine like that's
incredible like a magazine that i read i
was excited when i was on the cover
i literally it was really funny so
the last bell just rang for school clint
called me i answered my phone he was
like he was like oh my gosh you got the
cover
i literally ran down the hallway
screaming
and skipping i was so happy and all my
friends were like
what are you doing and i was like i got
the cover of entrepreneur magazine and
they were like what's that
so it's like it's just a different world
they just don't
like sometimes you have to hide your
successes because it seems like you're
gloating
yes yes i feel like well
only to certain people i feel like my
close friends
they're happy for me and they they
realize that
you know especially ones that i've been
friends with
since i was like young they realize how
much work i've put into it and how
passionate i am about it
and they're happy for me but like the
people at school that are just
like the mean girls and you know what i
realized
what i like to call the blonde mafias
who
you know were never very every school
has their click names oh yeah
i remember mine from high school too and
you know you realize what i mean right
oh yeah why
well they obviously they're
a little jealous that i'm verified on
instagram
but social media is such a kid thing
they
i mean i have to do it i feel like part
of my job i feel like but
it is it's life for people well that's
the same thing with me like i don't do
it because i
i want followers because i want to be
like some kind of like in instagram
influencer
i do it because it's good for marketing
like social media has such an influence
and if i want to you know grow the brand
get get the word out about it social
media is a great way to do it right
i'm not you know bragging so like
i'm so famous on social media so they're
insecure is the problem
yeah because the the when someone is
rude and mean to you they are projecting
their own insecurities about themselves
so it's really it's in you you seem
quite evolved so
this will be interesting for you to look
at as you move forward to see what
what people project on to you that
doesn't feel good because
you know it's reflecting who they are
not who you are so
these girls are or guys they're insecure
and they feel um as though
it's what they're getting from it is
that they're
they're recognizing that they haven't
accomplished that and they don't
like that feeling um so they're gonna
make they're gonna try to bring you down
to their level
and that happens all the time that
happens with you know whether you have a
million you know multi-million dollar
company or whether you're
you made varsity in your freshman year
like
they will find a way to bring you down
because they are insecure
so it's going to be really important for
you to maintain your
confidence and your level of awareness
for where
this source of contention and discomfort
comes from because
that's the stuff that's called bullying
right yeah i mean
it's not really about the person being
bullied it's about the bully right and
why they're doing it
and at the end of the day if you can get
to a point because this is what i had to
do with social media and with
other people that maybe i knew but some
of them i didn't
is that you have to really arrive at the
point where you feel
sympathy and you feel bad for them
because you you
understand it has nothing to do with you
and if it does and if you feel like a
certain level of insecurity
it's your checkpoint of like am i not
trying hard enough
was i mean to them did i say that
because i
did i say oh my god i got the cover of
the magazine because i wanted a reaction
right i want to be cool then that's your
problem and you have to figure that out
but if you're being authentic
and genuine and kind and you know
you know a good human being and they
treat you poorly
you'll come to the point where you
realize i feel bad for them because that
is their reality is that all they can do
is bring you down
that's going to be tough for you and
that's why i really kind of
i make a conscious effort to try and
keep it low profile in my personal life
yeah
um like at school you know people will
be like oh like why were you gone
like oh well i i just i just had a
meeting
that's all like there's no need to
expand on it there's no need to say
oh well well you know it was really
exciting like i
i got to like meet all these incredible
people because
there's no there's no point in doing
that i had my enjoyment with it
like it was exciting for me but that
doesn't mean i need to
talk about it or make anything
about me like you know i don't
need people saying oh well you know
alina
did this this this and that like and now
she's talking about it like
why does it matter it doesn't matter
like i'm cool at first though
it's hard because it's super cool at
first you're like guess who i met
and guess what i did so i definitely
have to kind of like
i realized okay i had the experience i'm
grateful that i had this experience
a lot of people don't have the
opportunities that i've had
and i realized that and i'm just need to
you know
keep it in check like you don't need to
talk about it you don't need to
because it it oh the reality of it even
if i
wouldn't mean to make someone feel bad
it could come off like i'm trying to
brag about it and then someone could end
up feeling bad about it and that's the
last thing i would want
so do you ever feel bad and do you ever
get to that point do you feel
um offended or sad or insecure
i mean do you get to that point
sometimes um
about things i've said or like things
get to you
i mean i'll see like comments
on like like videos not not necessarily
on my personal account
but like on videos that i've done on
like that they've appeared on like other
people's instagrams
or like big like media outlets on uh
instagram
and i'll look at the comments and it's
just like
and i just i think about it and i
you know sometimes i want to be petty
and i want to respond i want to be like
you know like it's it's not nice to like
say stuff like that and like
you know it does hurt and it's like
it's hard cause it's what do you do then
who do you go to
i just think about i say
you know responding
give them what they want if it looks
like
you know it's it's hard
not to react because i feel like i
definitely
have kind of a i have a personality
where i will snap back like if somebody
says something to my face i'll be like
no like that's not okay like don't say
that
but you know on social media things can
really get twisted around to sound
really bad
um so there's no cadence or anything
there's no inflection it's just words
yeah so you know
i can just sit there and i say okay keep
smiling so you have to journalize
so you internalize it yeah really and
well also like i do tend to like read
them like when i'm with like my mom or
my dad or like my friends and they're
like
just let it go yeah let it go but you
don't have anyone that you talk to about
when you're up when you're upset
well you know my parents are definitely
very
they definitely tell me they're like
it's
it could have nothing to do with you it
could be something that somebody else is
going through
and they just need an outlet and social
media
is obviously has been an outlet for
people just to
hate on other people and makes them feel
better about themselves
and honestly i'm kind of at the point
where
if it makes you feel about it better
about yourself
there's nothing i can do about it like
if that's what you choose to do
with your like your like anonymous
like social media account um
it's just not my it's there's nothing i
can do about it
only one solution to this you need to
get a burner account
and you need to just burn them all
no that usually gets found out yeah
those are yeah that
well i think it's important because like
whether you know for me in my life too
no matter what point i've been at
there's got to be somebody that you can
go to when stuff
is difficult and shoot i mean if it's
got to be a therapist it's a therapist
but if it's your parents it's your
parents
if it's a friend it's a friend um but
you know there should be
that there should be a you know there
should be people that you can go to when
things are difficult because
that that's life yeah like that's life i
mean i like whether you're doing what
you're doing or what i'm doing or
what anyone else is you got to have
someone to sound off to so that you can
you know go through your own therapy oh
yeah 100 yeah and i really like i talked
to my parents about it i'm just like
i don't understand like why people yeah
like
do this and like i'll talk to my friends
about it but i feel like i've definitely
kind of been taught from a young age
just rise above that's good that's what
that's really what my dad says every
time like something
yeah like that something is like said or
like
i mean somebody cuts me off on the
highway
and it's like wait you're driving well
no no but like
hypothetically i mean i was illegally
driving at 14. in fact actually my
sister and i
were driving around my parents building
they were in construction
and uh my dad had a truck and so we were
so small we were probably
i don't know six seven years old maybe
five six seven years old and one of us
would work the steering and one would
work the pedals
and they thought this was totally
acceptable i'm like oh my god my parents
were so brave
um but let me i have driven in a
graveyard
good job you need lessons i can help you
out oh i i
i i'll teach you the shortcuts to you
know
going first at a stop sign and things
like that the things that i got taught
when i was my dad was like
you know alina if you're going to learn
how to drive you might as well learn
somewhere where you can't hurt anyone
so you took me to a graveyard and i was
like they're all fair enough that's good
fair enough morbid and wonderful um
actually your parents is something that
i want to talk to you about because
um you know i have my own experience
with parents and like i said my parents
worked for me
and um when i started um when i started
racing indy cars in 2005.
they started working for me and they
they started working full time and they
would do
everything from driving my bus to you
know
negotiating deals to managing my
finances to my schedule
they did everything and you know at that
point in time it really was the best
safest option
right it just was who else could i trust
at that point in time
um you know and then i paid them and um
but it's a challenging situation i
i would advise i i would advise anyone
to have a plan for that
so i don't know if you've even thought
about that or not or what
maybe has changed because my parents
became
not really my parents they were you know
they would call
and i'd be like oh god what do they want
or i just wouldn't answer because i'm
like it was always about work it was
always about business
and um you know i think it's this it's
an interesting dynamic
and you know i know your dad's sitting
here right now and you're probably
cringing listening to this but this is
important advice as a as a
someone with the experience um how has
that dynamic changed and and maybe
you'll be an anomaly and it'll just flow
perfectly and maybe
who knows maybe someday you'll have a
dream of something else and they'll run
this company and you'll be doing
something completely different i don't
know but
you know what's the been the dynamic
shift with
this level of involvement from your
from your parents with you know them
working for you essentially but really
probably doing a lot of the work
essentially well it definitely
i mean as for level of involvement they
are very involved yeah
um you know like i mentioned my dad
runs the business while i'm at school he
manages the company
um also he worked as a business
consultant right before well that's
gonna be a lot of the business
i mean so let's go from eight til three
so you know i mean that's most of the
day
yeah and i mean like after school i i go
there
and i work and i work at home and i
you know respond to emails when i'm at
school um
but you know there
there is kind of that that that trust
there where it's like okay
like i definitely like take the wheel
yeah right well it's just kind of it it
has to be that way
and you know
we we are a family-owned company so the
majority owners are me and my younger
sister
and then my dad owns a little bit and
then we have investors as well
my mom she is like the schedule
like master like my schedule is crazy
like on a day-to-day basis it is
boom boom boom boom go to bed that's it
like not a lot of free time
um and your choice
yes yes and no um
i have the option not to dance but i
choose to anyways
i had the option not to be on the palm
team but i chose to anyways
um do you have the option to not do a
business call
or not fly out to california or not i do
i do um you know kind of at this point
in the beginning we were definitely more
like oh well you have this opportunity
like
we need to take this opportunity yeah i
know how that feels you want to do it
exactly exactly and you know definitely
as i kind of get older
and i kind of just realize
some things just aren't as important as
as others and you have to choose what
has fallen by
what has fallen away for you um certain
trips
i've had to miss like fun trips or work
trips
um well we try to make every work trip a
little fun well yes that's good
that's good that's great that's a good
thing to do my dad taught me that
finally at some point he's like try and
make these trips fun i'm like yeah
that's a good idea
um so i have had to miss
trade shows and you know
luckily i have a great team that that
steps up and goes
and um then
there's obviously the email that comes
after from the reporter oh
i wish i could have seen you there and
i'm just like
i'm trying to make it to everything but
sometimes it's just not gonna happen
right
and if i can't i just can't overstretch
myself and then burn out
yeah because it's not worth it to try
and make every little thing
that everyone wants from me you just
kinda gotta
sit back take or take a step back and
look at it
and think how impactful is it going to
be
is it going to be as impactful as this
next thing that i have
sure and you know sometimes the answer
is yes
sometimes the answer is no right and
when the answer is no it's a hard thing
to turn down
but so you have to tell me how your
dynamic has changed with a family
you just told me how busy you are
well you know the family dynamic hasn't
really changed all that much
really just because i've kind of grown
up with it
[Music]
being so young and kind of starting it
i guess i never really realized
that it changed because you don't know
what the difference is right you've
never experienced any other dynamics so
you wouldn't know
yeah right right and you know i feel
like
and now i kind of look at it and i'm
like oh well you know other kids lives
aren't like this
right but mine is and that's right what
i've kind of
always known so i i don't feel like that
you'll realize at some point in time if
something needs to change right i mean
that's what
i mean like i basically needed to tell
my parents to do things differently and
it got really hard to get to the point
where i could
basically yell at my parents i can't do
that like i
tell them how to do something they're
the ones that taught me how to walk you
know
how am i going to tell them how to do
that do do something you know it's a
weird dynamic so
you know i i think it is the best case
scenario until
something else happens because because
they're the ones that you can trust they
see you every single day
like they're you're the the integration
is obviously
you know it's family so um but you'll
know someday if something doesn't feel
right or if you want to make a change or
you know you you feel uncomfortable and
you know i hit that point in my life but
i think it's
you seem pretty mature so you know it's
something to keep on the radar is like
you know maybe i think my parents were
relieved actually when it happened
because
you know they got to get on with their
life too and um
you know they they got to have some of
their own identity again
but it's an interesting dynamic working
with your family no matter whether it's
young
whether you're a kid or whether you're
all adults and you're trying to run a
restaurant or whatever
it's working with family is really is
really challenging and it takes a
ginormous amount of um i love when i say
words that aren't in a dictionary
um of communication
yes you have to tell each other how
you're feeling all the time
and your discomforts because that builds
into resentment and then all of a sudden
you're in three days of therapy crying
your eyes out because you realize that
you got to the point of no return
eventually
you know those kinds of things can
happen in life so stay honest with that
um i think that's important and i feel
like
definitely we try and find that balance
um my parents
you know they tell me or my dad
especially he tells me
you know you can
you can make like you can disagree with
me
and i feel like that's that was
definitely something that i kind of
struggled with the idea of
well if he has an idea and i'm you know
and i don't feel the same way about
you know if we should you know go this
way or we should go that way
can i say no
can i say i disagree
and he he definitely told me he was like
yes you can say no like you can you can
disagree
and he basically said like at the end of
the day
yes you are the boss but
you need to take into
account everyone else's opinion and
everyone
else's perspective you can't just say
hey
this is my opinion so this is a decision
and so i feel like growing up having
that mindset
i was definitely always asking everyone
well do you have another take on it or
do you does anybody else
you know want to want to throw out an
idea
and i feel like that's kind of how we
run the company now
with our team we're very communicative
communicative yeah communicative um
and one of our big things is also don't
assume
so don't just assume you're right right
don't just assume that
this is the way that everyone wants it
to be great you should read a book
called the four agreements
is it good it's great yeah four
agreements is about you know just core
principles of life and
and one is to not assume um
but yeah i'm trying to get into more
like businessy books too this is not
this is more spiritual
this is more like life lessons
you know like one of them's always do
your best so
things like that and it goes into these
four but um why can
i write down some good books for you
when we're done um so as the boss
like what what is your full vision for
zolly candy
um give me the grand
where i see this like what's your
fullest vision that you have right now
i definitely say
you know as a business goal we want to
be the number one selling
sugar-free uh candy in america in the
world
even um
we also you know want to
grow our non-profit to
um 22 million uh smiles
yeah you guys have a charity that you
yeah so donate to tell me about that
yeah so um you know after i kind of
found out that
you know tooth decay is the single
greatest epidemic i was like this is
what i want to
make the product about this is what i
want to
i want to create like a a non-profit or
a foundation
around this company yeah
so we give free lollipops to schools
across america to teach kids about the
importance of oral health care and
entrepreneurship
it originally started at 250 000 smiles
then 500 000 smiles then
1 million and then 2 million so this is
how many
lollipops you've yes given out for free
to
donated to school so like every year we
kind of bump it up even more
um and that's how many how many
lollipops
um for like teachers who sign up they
sign up on our website and
it's a like two minutes of a survey and
it's just it's a great
it's a great program um
there's 22 million elementary school
kids
and you know end goal is we get to 22
million we've grown to 2 million
on our own and i'm thinking you know
if we got that far on our own how far
can we get with like a partner
or like someone else you know just
adding that rocket fuel behind it to
just
bump a sponsor or somebody that's
willing to you know promote the
cause and and not only just like a
sponsor but a partner
someone who can not just provide money
but
you know provide like a guidance
or at the very least just be passionate
about you know
what we're what we're talking about what
we're trying to do here and that's
that's always
really important when we what we look
for in like a team member
um or you know anyone that we work with
we just want them to be passionate do
you hire people
i do that's amazing it's lots of fun
do you fire people has anyone been fired
yet
maybe no did you fire him um
no yeah that's tough yeah i
i just i didn't i wasn't like you're
fired it was like uh
i don't think this is working out
and i had to fire my parents so it
doesn't get any worse than that
it's just those decisions you gotta make
you know you gotta look for the best
interest in the company it doesn't make
them bad people it doesn't
doesn't make you a bad person you're
firing them of course not no and like
look at everything leads to the next
thing they might just need to move on
anyway and
it's hard for people to move on i think
people generally have a problem with
change
and they fear the unknown and they fear
something going away forever i don't
think they're actually
i think that it really leads to better
things yeah because it's all part of the
process but
um but but firing can be a little
overwhelming yeah
[Laughter]
and i don't want to fire anyone and i'm
37.
you know as a kid like i was always like
oh
would i get to fire someone be like
you're fired get out
but like it turns out i don't feel like
donald trump i'm not confident i'm not
comfortable
i'm not deliberate i want to it takes a
lot longer and
it's not fun i just want to be nice
but i have a question for you oh go for
it um
so i feel like we definitely kind of
have experienced
similar things both working in kind of
male dominated you know lines of work
um i know you've you've definitely
said like you know i was a woman in
in a male dominated kind of like racing
industry which was always
um what definitely what i thought was
super cool
and i
you know working in like going into
candy i guess i never realized that
it's all men like there's no women
there's no like did you know that
there's never been a female
um female ceo of um
uh of um makeup company
i think i heard that the other day i was
like are you kidding me
that that can't be true now though well
it's just business though right
so it's about being respected it's about
being valued it's about having people
that trust you it's about having people
that
um you know treat you the way that you
deserve to be treated and believe in you
which is what i always said was the
hardest part for me
is that just having people believe in me
truly not just like
do their job because the difference
between doing your job and doing an
excellent job is
vastly different you can show up for
work and look like you're doing your job
i mean if you've watched office space
it's possible
if you haven't watched office space it's
funny you should watch it anyway um
but but doing a great job is something
totally different and so
um getting people to believe in you to
the level that they're willing to
work at that next level and put their
and truly believe in you like a feeling
not just the
words like oh yeah i believe in you you
know that's really important
yeah and that's that's a big thing with
us too
we definitely look for people that are
you know supportive and passionate um
you just surround yourself yes yeah um
i guess just how how did you
not get just like really
like to the point where you wanted to
quit and you're just like i just don't
want to do this anymore
like nobody respects me i
i get super outcasted like i'm sure well
at least in
in what i've experienced like even as
like just in like middle school and high
school like
you will get left out of clicks and
that's just how it is
like i'm sure the the male drivers you
know they went out and they
had their fun and i experienced that
when i was in england i lived in england
from 16 to 19 years old on my own
and um the guys really were out on their
own like they made they left me out a
lot
for sure and i mean i could imagine like
i mean and i mean
i didn't have girlfriends so that those
were my only friends
so how did i deal with that yeah um
i mean i think that it's important that
you can have your goods good good
friends
and support support system around you um
have to keep your goals in mind i mean
you have to understand what you're doing
it for i think the fact that you have a
charity to benefit
i think is a really good foundational
goal that extends beyond the company
that's really positive and emotional and
is a good connection point i think that
you have to find the confidence in
yourself i mean if you
you have to do things that that educate
you so get educated you should know your
you should know your stuff
um because knowledge is power that's for
that's for sure
if you walk into a meeting and you know
you've done your homework and you know
about them and you know about the
brand you know the brand you know about
the you know about
sales numbers and roi and bottom lines
and net and gross
and all the stuff going on like look
they're going to have to respect you so
knowing your stuff is going to be really
important i think
[Music]
your dedication and determination and
then be humble
right there's no let your company speak
for itself let your
let your cover speak for itself isn't it
it's a lot cooler if somebody
goes and walks through
the airport let's say going somewhere
and they see you on the cover and
they're like they come back to school
and they're like oh my god we saw you
that is so much cooler than you having
to tell them yeah
so and understand why why you would be
expressing and like why you would want
people to know
right and we all want to be recognized
and we all and especially early on when
things are going on it's very exciting
but
it's coming from a place of insecurity
too it's coming from
or a gloating sort of space where
you want to be acknowledged for the
things that you're doing because it's
unique and cool and different and you
want to stand out and
um you know you just just have to
self-identify while you're doing that
but
the most important thing is that you
have a really good group around you that
you do your homework and work really
hard and
and follow your passion it will
resonate with people if you're doing
something that you really love to do it
resonates with people you will
permeate this like light and energy and
joy about something
and everyone will feel that and they'll
want to be a part of that
so stay true to that and it and it might
be
it might be zolly candy for life and it
might just be for another two years
it doesn't really matter it doesn't
matter i mean i retired at 37 36
i'm 37 now um
yeah i was 36 years old and i retired
i'm that's very young to retire so
it's easy to get self-identified with
you
what you've made yourself to be but just
understand
it's just life and it just doesn't
matter
what really matters is you're doing
something that you really enjoy and love
don't ever feel like you have to do
something
there's going to be things along the way
that you have to do a meeting that you
have to do or something like that but
like the over
over the the overlying feeling for it
all should be
something that you truly want um and
there'll be a little grunt work along
the way but the rest of it should be fun
and also understand that the things that
energize
you and lift you up and and make you
feel good
no matter how much effort they are and
work they are
those are the things you should be doing
if you're doing something that drains
you
and makes you feel exhausted and
resentful and angry
and bitter or irritable
um and tired those things are not for
you
it took me a long time to learn that but
um
i've only learned that in the last
couple of years but that that is true so
sort of identify your energy levels with
things if you're doing something that's
for you
it will make you feel good
yeah that's great well
the last thing i want to ask you because
i think that there's going to be a lot
of
parents that are listening with kids and
you have done incredible things already
and
you you're an inspiration no matter what
age
i think that it would be beneficial to
really
identify maybe the values or
lessons that you have been
taught or things that have been
instilled into you from a young age from
your parents
that have made you into this human being
that is
ambitious and confident and has a vision
and dreams and wants greater things
and i think that i think that that would
be really beneficial for the for the
parents listening so
what have you found to be the biggest
benefits to put you in the place that
you are now
um
[Music]
you know i don't really know if i
understand the question
well like you know um so what happened
so like let's say you grow up and maybe
like for me let's say
my dad was always a dreamer so i got
that from him i feel like where
i would visualize things into their
fullest extent like i would visualize
way i have i'm i would i would say i'm a
dreamer because my dad taught me to be a
dreamer
he taught me to be a hard worker he
taught me i mean by leading by example
when i was a kid my parents would they
own their own business and we would go
and hang out at their shop while they
cut glass and metal and frame things up
until two o'clock in the morning we'd be
sleeping in sleeping bags in their
office
while they were working we they led by
example but taught us hard work
and they taught us that you know that
that is what was necessary to get what
you wanted in life so things like that
like what have they
what kind of values like you know um i
think you've already said one of them
which was
um you know rise above you know i think
that's a great lesson so are there other
things like that that
someone that is a parent with a kid
that's
five six seven eight nine ten any any of
those transitional years when they're
younger
could could um you know teach their kids
that would help them to become
you know someone like you that's goal
oriented and confident
and ambitious yeah i mean
definitely throughout throughout my life
um
there's been a lot of uh you know little
sayings that have been just kind of like
drilled into my brain and that i live by
now
um one of them being uh
you know my dad used to tell me this and
he still tells me this every night
before i go to bed
um since i was probably
two or three um he said alina
you're an amazing woman you can do
anything if you work hard try believe
and never give up
and it's just like a a short little
sentence but
you know it's it's pretty much like a
key to life
yeah you know work hard try believe
never give up
it's all you got to do make something
happen
um and also never lose your cool yeah
so i feel like i you know
i'm pretty opinionated i'm pretty
loud um and
it's it's hard when people are you know
constantly you know questioning
your authority or questioning you know
if you're really
um if i'm really you know actually doing
anything in the company if i'm
if this is really you know my invention
you know i grew up
two people at my school telling me oh
well this is her dad's company
they just put her face on the package
and
you just gotta never lose your cool
just say no i
work on it every day rise above what i
want to do so
you just gotta never lose your cool and
you know because usually the reason
you'd be losing your cool
is not worth it it's not worth your time
your energy
the oxygen that you would be wasting
um and so it's good it's usually just
not worth it
um those are good lessons yeah it'll
serve you well
oh and of course this one's a a huge one
in business
uh especially is ask questions if you
don't know
ask yeah that kind of goes like right
along with never assume just ask
um i mean i honestly would wouldn't even
be close to where i am today if i didn't
ask questions
if i didn't just like if i if i was
stubborn and i just
you know didn't want to seem like like i
knew everything
it would be an insecurity right because
you'd be like i don't want to ask
because i don't want them to think i
don't know
exactly yeah it's endearing to ask for
help
and it's just you know that's what i
always tell people because i feel like
especially adults yeah um that are
trying to get into business
they're just too afraid to ask they're
too afraid to sacrifice their ego
to ask a question and i
that's why i think you know kitchen is
business kids should be in business
because kids ask questions
because kids don't care what other
people think of them i mean especially
young kids they're just like
i'm doing me you know yeah that's a
fantastic perspective high five
i think you've got it figured out pretty
well at 14 and um you should be very
proud of yourself and i'm
sure your parents are very proud of you
oh you know i try and make them proud
thank you thank you so much thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today i hope you enjoyed
it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button
you